- You doing, what are you
doing to fill your time?
- This is it, I just beg
people to be on their show,
because I have nothing,
we are in lockdown.
No, my kids are obviously, I have
a senior in high school,
and a sophomore in high school,
and so they're home,
they're homeschooling,
and it's--
- Oh, I'm sorry
for your senior, 'cause this
is like graduation year.
- Yeah, it's a tough beat.
I mean, you know, he has a girlfriend,
so they had prom canceled.
They did a little prom thing
in their backyard the other day,
just to try and make something special,
but spring break and prom, and graduation,
and he plays spring sports.
That was canceled, and so yeah,
it's a tough way to go out.
- But this is actually,
this is an amazing thing
'cause I was just actually
speaking with The Voice
about how long they've
been on or whatever.
And Blake has been there forever,
but you've been with the Bachelor.
That's 18 years, is that what
- Yeah
- 18 years--
- That's right
That's your kid, that's your,
that's your kid going to college,
like that's, that's amazing.
Like are, do you feel
like you're a relationship
expert at this point, is my,
'cause I feel like you're probably
really good at a
relationship how you speak.
- Well it's funny how you
put that in perspective
because so, my son was six weeks old
when I got the job and so
when he shows up on set
now he's six foot two
and a big college kid,
and everyone's like oh
my gosh, that's how long
we've been doing this
show, it's horrifying.
But it is, you know, how long you've been
doing the show, the show's
going to college now.
But I feel like, you
know, I am not a doctor,
but I definitely should have some sort
of honorary degree in phycology
(laughs)
of dealing with relationships
'cause I have truly seen it all
and I've been through it
myself and seen it on TV.
- Yeah, of all the people
you've had on this show,
who have you wanted to scream at most
(laughs loudly)
- Well it'd be
- Who have you been like
look you need to take a minute
(laughs)
- Gosh, I don't know
if there's anyone who's
ever been on the show I
haven't wanted to do that.
I mean, even this last season with Peter
I wanted to just grab
him by the shirt collar
and be like, "Come on
man, pull it together".
'Cause he was a mess
coming down the stretch,
and Colton obviously jumping the fence
and running away from me in
the Portuguese countryside.
So yeah, and even Hannah
and I had our moments,
so I think with probably every
- So much drama.
- Probably with every
Bachelor and Bachelorette
there is that moment where they want
to scream at me, and sometimes they do.
And I want to yell at them, but that's,
that's part of, honestly I do get involved
in these people's lives
and I do care about them.
And I think when you do love people,
it's not that you abuse
them, that's not love,
but I think you do have
those heated moments
where you're really telling your truth.
- Yeah, I think if you don't, if you don't
care about someone then
you don't, you don't care
about telling the truth.
You're just like whatever,
I'm just going to move along.
- Exactly, yeah.
- Yeah, I think it means something
when you do get heated, that means that
you're involved, you're invested.